there's a loss in the universe I call it
the Law of Attraction and the law of
attraction is one that works like this
you get back from the universe from the
world what it is that you put out there
in the world and if you're putting out
there into the world that I am not
worthy of attracting Something Beautiful
into my life that the universe will
respond back to you with exactly that
message and the even more interesting
part about this you can't give away what
you don't have principle is that if your
message to the universe is gimme gimme
gimme which is a lot of people's message
to the universe I want this from you I
want that from you please give me this I
have to have that the universe's
response back to that kind of a
mentality is exactly the same the
universe will say right back to you over
and over again give me give me give me
and you'll find yourself never ever
arriving but always being in a state of
striving always feeling as if you're
being neglected never feeling as if you
have enough always feeling as if you're
being shortchanged because you're
constantly under the pressure to to give
to get back what the universe is
demanding from you hey it's Evan Carl
Michael and I make these videos because
of my first business I struggled to stay
afloat I quit my business partner and
the thing that kept me going was
studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how to shift your
attention with Dr Wayne Dyer
the irony of this is that if you shift
that and you say
to the universe to the world
how may I serve
how may I serve
the universe's response back to you is
how may I serve you
how may I serve you
and it's very intriguing when you take
your energy and your attention off of
what you are demanding from the world
and instead saying what can I give to
the world
and it's really the the basis behind
that very famous line of the uh
President John Kennedy's inaugural
address ask not what your country can
ask what you can do for your country and
the irony of that is and I've learned
that in my own life that when I stopped
thinking about what was in it for Wayne
Dyer and how much could I get and I
began to shift and say how can I help
you how can I give to you what can I do
for you and people who write to me I
send them something
when when I encounter somebody that
needs help of some kind I'm very often
just giving that to them and then I find
that it just keeps coming back into my
life and once I shifted that energy off
of what can I have
into what can I give it seemed to me
that the Universe responded back with
the very same message what can I give to
you and the most incredible and
wonderful and beautiful abundance has
flowed into my life in every way that I
can possibly think of you can't give
away what you don't have
so take a look at an inventory of what
you do have
how much do you love yourself
how much kindness do you have in you how
much peace do you have in you how much
joy do you have in you and if you're
able to give that away as many times as
you can in a given day watch and see how
much more of that continues to show up
and come back in your life rule number
two is align yourself with the mission I
was trained earliest to be a jungian
analyst by Carl Jung
and Carl Jung once observed he said
he's talking about this this idea that
within each and every one of us there is
this purpose and he said at the same
moment
at the same moment
that you are a protagonist in your own
life
and you're making choices
at the very same moment
you're also the spear carrier or the
extra
in a much larger drama
and he concluded that and I've never
forgotten this he said all of you
are doomed
to make choices
it sounds like such a paradox if you're
doomed how can you be making a choice
so let me bring it into looking first at
your own body
and you heard the doctor speaking before
about about your bodies and uh
so much of what he was saying I align
with and relate to
our bodies
are what we are what we are given to
live out this Incarnation this time on
this planet
I happen to be given a male body that's
about six foot two and um it has the
hair that used to grow on its head and
now grows in its ears and
all of these things there's like this is
this is what I was doomed to I mean I'm
not going to be in a female body I'm not
going to be in a body that has brown
eyes when I have blue eyes and so on so
in a sense you are given this body
but you also have choices to make
and the choices that you make within
this sense of being doomed which is what
he meant when he said you're a
protagonist in your own life but you're
also a spirit carrier in a much larger
drama
that there is something bigger moving
all of these pieces around
and this thing that is bigger that's
moving the pieces around is something
that you have to align with and you can
align with it in your body by treating
It Well by feeding it the Applause line
real food by exercising by watching how
you relate to this body you can make a
huge difference but you're still in this
context of being doomed
to make choices
now look at the rest of your life all of
the things that brought you to this
place to this day right here in your
life
and most of us
have come into this into this place
where we don't recognize this
fundamental truth
that within each and every one of us
there is this um this capacity that I
have in my one of my most recent books
called wishes fulfilled I call it my the
I am discourses
the word I am
see
if you want to be able to change
something about yourself or to align
yourself with this Divine mission in
which you say yes I have been doomed to
do all of these things but there are
choices that I can make rule number
three is surrender all your possessions
one of the things that I have learned is
that there is always
something bigger
moving the pieces around
even when we think that we're
we're the one who are making the choices
Carl Jung once said that at the same
moment that you are uh
making choices in your life you are also
the spear carrier
or the extra
in a much larger drama
and he said
in effect we are all doomed
to make choices
you see the paradox
we're doomed
we're not doing anything we're all just
being done
and yet within that larger context of
being done
we're also making choices
but it really boils down to a
realization that Who We Are Who each and
every one of us
our our Essence is
is not this body that we're in and these
physical choices that we're making
I asked my audiences frequently uh how
many
how many bodies have you been in since
you incarnated into this planet on this
lifetime
because
um
one of the great teachers and sages of
my life a man named muktananda
in India was asked the question what is
real Swami what is real
and he said
that is real
which never changes
so anything that is changing
doesn't meet the definition of being
real
so who are you
what part of you meets that definition
certainly not that body that you're in
we've all been in so many bodies since
we showed up
we were all in a little body about this
big it weighed seven or eight or nine
pounds
and we were all in a body that was this
big a little toddler and a teenage body
and a 20 year old body and for some
a body that has gone on they've been in
Many Bodies up and through the 70s and
80s like myself 71 years of age
um
and if you think that body that you were
in is real
then you must have thought that about
your 10 year old body as well
so I invite you to go out
and bring that 10 year old body in here
and we'll talk to it
and you smirk and laugh and so on
because you realize that that's
impossible because it's not real it
doesn't exist Does it
and the same is true of the body that
you walked into this beautiful church
here in Assisi tonight
it will be different
when you walk out
you'll walk out of here with a different
body than you walked in with
so that
by that definition
this is all just an illusion
it's just constantly changing and
therefore it isn't real
but there is a part of each and every
one of us that can remember being in
that 10 year old body
and that observed it and noticed it
and that you can close your eyes and be
there you can do everything you did when
you were 10 or 12 or 20 or 30 or
whatever
and so it is to that
element of your consciousness of your
awareness of your reality that I address
this these remarks
not the body not our physical
possessions but uh our soul our spirit
our divine mind whatever we call it
it is
it is to that that is the only thing
that is real
and when we learn to live from there
from that that place I call it the
higher place the higher self or the
highest self
the part of us that realize is that all
of us you know the poet T.S Eliot said
that we shall not cease
from exploration
but at the end of all of our exploring
will be to return to the place
from which we originated
but to know it for the first time
the poet spoke of death
I don't
I believe we can return to that place
from which we originated
call it the Dao call it God call it soul
and come to know it
and as my awareness of the man who this
city
[Music]
um brought up and is honored by his
presence
he was actually known as
God's buffoon
God's full
wherever he would go he would be mocked
and he was really trying to teach all of
us to let go of our attachment to our
possessions
to our bodies to who we are in fact he
believed that the only way you can get
closer to God
was to remove all of your
uh all of your attachments to uh your
stuff to what you own
and instead come from a place of pure
and divine love
and this Gathering here for this
Miraculous Journey that we're all on
began as an idea
I think it was my idea but
I know that something bigger is always
moving the pieces around
and I'm always aware that even though I
think that it's me making the choices I
also know that uh
I'm also the spear carrier or the extra
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching watch this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just enjoy this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is free yourself
from Human limitations once you're in
that state of God realization
you'll understand things like your
intuition that is that inner calling
that says go this way instead of that
way try this don't be afraid of that get
rid of the fears that are so dominating
your life as Anita talks about fear and
and what a thing it wasn't created the
cancer in her life which allowed her to
uh to almost come to a place of dying
you'll discover things like
synchronicity that you have a thought
and all of a sudden what you place your
attention on begins to manifest and
arrive into your life you'll discover
that those thoughts are not just things
that just are happenstance there's no
happenstance in this entire universe
it's all held together by a Divine Light
and one of my favorite readings I'd like
to share with you is from the life and
teachings of the Masters of the Far East
it said it has been clearly stated that
life lived by the average individual is
Hypnotic that is the majority of men and
women are not living life as it was
intended at all
not one in a million feels the freedom
to live what he inwardly feels he should
live he has come under the world's
opinion of himself and this opinion is
what he obeys rather than the laws of
his own being in this respect and to
this degree he is living under an
hypnotic spell it's like hypnosis he
lives under the delusion that he is a
mere human being living in a merely
material world and only hopes to escape
it when he dies and goes to what he
calls heaven this is not the
determination intended in the plan and
purpose of life obedience to one's inner
nature the expression of life as he
instinctively feels it ought to be
expressed is the very foundation of the
life which the Masters reveal as the
only true mode of living that is very
powerful awareness that you are not this
body that you're in this body that comes
and it goes you are the invisible Divine
intelligence within the same
intelligence that allows a clay pot to
exist and finally from the masters of
the Far East the second volume the
moment you become free from the belief
that you are mere human beings subject
to human laws of life and death and the
limitations with human beings have
imposed that moment you will see that
you are free from all human limitations
and may become sons of God if you will
the moment you realize that you are
Divine that you you are free from all
limitations and possessed of the
strength of divinity and you know that
this Divinity is the place where being
comes most directly in contact with God
man is then beginning to see and know
that this Divinity is not something to
be injected into each other from without
he is beginning to know that is the very
life of each and every person your
essence The Light Within you this is
what this course is about this is a
course that we go deeply in depth in and
the reason that I put the course
together in the first place is because I
have heard no nothing but positive
enlightening comments from people who
say it turned my life around I finally
went within and discovered that I am
capable of using this Divine
intelligence that we call light inside
of us to create the life that I was
destined to live rule number five is
treasure your divinity the next
principle is called treasuring your
divinity
treasuring your Divinity there's a
wonderful observation that I saw from
Emerson in self-reliance
it's about trusting your Divinity
knowing that you are connected to your
Source knowing that you are a Divine
creation and that there are no accidents
he said a man should learn to detect and
watch that gleam of light
which flashes across his mind from
within
more than the luster of the firmament of
bards and Sages
yet he dismisses without notice his own
thought
because it's his own
in every work of Genius we recognize our
own rejected thoughts they come back to
us with a certain alienated Majesty
we often reject our thoughts and we see
the things that we think of as Grand and
as genius and we reject them because
they're our own
treasuring our Divinity instead of being
terrified of it knowing that I am always
connected to my source there is no way
that I cannot because it is in you and I
am in you and you are in me and you can
never be separated from it there is no
place that this source is not it grows
everybody's fingernails it beats
everybody's Hearts it digests
everybody's Foods it opens all the
flowers and you're always connected to
it rule number six is learn how to step
back I was reading a book that was sent
to me by a friend in England it was
written by Rashad field it was called it
was part of a Trilogy and it was the
middle book of a trilogy it was called
to know we are loved
and I was reading that book and I came
across about four lines
that just intrigued me so much I was
reading them over and over and over
again
and this is what they said I made it the
display quote for this book
it said
he was talking to someone who was very
close to dying
and he said
if we stop for a moment
it is possible to perceive a pattern in
our lives
the motivators that have influenced us
become much more obvious
we are able to see life unfolding from
both ends at once
coming into the present moment
but until we get to a certain point of
realization
this is not possible
because everything is still seen
as a series of apparent causes and
effects
that you have to be able to get to a
place in your life where you can step
back
and realize that there are really two
kinds of time
one of the kinds of time is what I call
horizontal time or cause and effect time
or the scientists called Cronus time
phonological time
this happens and then this happens and
this causes this and this is the cause
and effect and we have a tendency in our
lives as we look at all of the things
that happen to us in our lives to
believe that everything has a cause and
effect relationship and so the reason
that I am here today is because of all
the things that I have done all the
choices that I have made and they have
led me to this place
but then there's another kind of time
and this is the kind of time that is
called Eternal time
and this is a line that doesn't go
horizontal it goes vertical it goes
straight up to our source of being to
the place that we come from
and this line is
um a kind of time that
um is deathless
and is worthless and is eternal and it
is always there
and when you get to a place in your life
where you cross that line when you see
the place where horizontal time at
vertical time cross
you have this realization
that me this personal me this ego of
mine is not the thing that's making all
of the choices that there's something
else that is involved
I called my publisher
and I said to him I want to step back
I want to step back from my life because
I know that there have been forces or
powers or some kind of energy that has
been impacting me throughout my entire
life
and I've been able to step back and as
it says in this quotation it's so
important to realize that it isn't
everything isn't just coming from the
past there are things that are coming
from the future and as well that we're
all always pulling out it's like I just
uh talked to someone who has a little a
little baby a little baby's just a few
months old and I said you realize that
that little baby's wisdom teeth
are already there
they're not going to come out of the
past
they're already there we're going to
pull them out of the future they're not
going to show up for another 20 years or
so and that they're going to be choices
to be made at that time what do you do
with them do you leave them in do you
cut them out all kinds of things but
there is this sense that not only is
there a chronological cause and effect
time taking place but there's this
eternal time in which everything about
for example our entire physical being
has already been handled for us
and I was like what your height is going
to be and what the color of your skin is
going to be what the color of your eyes
are going to be and when your hair is
going to fall out I know the experience
very well
so what I decided to do was to take a
look at
um what were the circumstances and the
people and the events and the things
that's kept showing up in my life going
all the way back to the time that I was
just a little baby all the way up to
just recently at the age of 73 which is
the age I am now is we recorded this
show
something took a hold of me and said
write this and I wrote and I wrote and I
wrote just because there was something
that was pulling me in the direction of
this is something that I absolutely had
to do and I started to realize that
that's really the story of my entire
life and there's a story of all the rest
of our lives as well and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is see yourself as
Divine love in the time I have left I
want to talk to you about walking down
another Street
and um
this other street is a street in which
you have an awareness
that
not only do you have
a physical body
but you have come to believe
that this physical body is who you are
and that you have locked yourself into
these five senses
and decided
that whatever evidence they provide for
you
is how you identify and Define your
reality
by what I see by What I Hear by what I
smell but my wife my life what looks
like by how much money I have by the
stuff that I possess and this is the
world of the ego and this is the world
of the false self according to my
teacher
Nissan
Maharaja in India
who passed away in 1986.
the false self is the ego
the ego is the part of us that has come
to believe that who I am is defined by
these six things who I am is what I have
and so we spend a big hunk of our life
attempting to get as much stuff as we
possibly can the Dao teaches something
very different let go of everything you
have
when I moved to Maui in 2005 full time I
gave up everything that I owned
everything twenty thousand books all of
my photographs records of every
description of furniture all the things
in the house all my clothing
shoes it was all donated to people who
lived on the underneath a bypass on in
Florida
and um let go of all of it
so the ego teaches us you are what you
have
the Dow teaches us
let go of everything that you had
do less and accomplish more
one of laosue's most famous observations
was I do nothing
and leave nothing undone
my son has taken to becoming a spiritual
Taoist
every time I tell him to do something he
says
I do nothing
and I leave nothing undone
but there's much wisdom in that I could
go on into that
the second thing that the ego teaches us
is that who I am is not only what I have
but who I am is what I do what I
accomplish
and so we spend a big hunk of Our Lives
believing that the way that we become
quote successful happy fulfilled
self-actualized whatever it might be is
on the basis of what I accomplish what
my resume looks like
um how many promotions I get and so we
send our children off to school
and we ask them to learn
to
identify themselves on how much they get
and what they accomplish your grades
become more important than what it is
that you are studying
what you own what clothes you wear what
labels you have and so on and we become
obsessed with this kind of absurdity and
we this is the false self at work
the third thing that the ego teaches us
is that
I am what other people think of me
I am my reputation
so becoming obsessed with our reviews
what people think of us
other people's opinions getting the
approval of others we talk about peer
group
approval needs and so on I have eight
children that aren't concerned about
those things
they were never raised with that kind of
a mentality the whole idea of you know
trying to please other people was
something that they consist consistently
heard from their mother and myself that
this isn't important to us we don't uh
we're not attached to that and um
this kind of an attachment so the Dao
teaches us
that what you think of me is none of my
business
what the ego teaches us is that what you
think of me is the most important thing
that I have and so I'll do whatever it
is that I need to do in order to get you
to agree with me to like me to approve
of me and so on
the fourth thing that the ego teaches us
this false self is that who I am is
separate
from everyone else
and so we are raised in this world of
the false self which teaches us that we
have to be in competition with everyone
else we have to defeat someone else
being number one is the most important
thing and you see people doing this all
the time at football games and you'll
see it when the Olympics come up you
know that the gold medal is more
important than anything else and if I
don't you'll see people weeping and
sobbing over this idea that um
I have to I have to be better than
somebody else in order to be fulfilled
in my life
the fifth thing that the ego teaches us
is that I am separate not only from
everybody else
but that I am separate from what's
missing in my life
The Tao teaches us
that there is no place that God is Not
if there is no place that God is Not
then God must be in you
and if there is no place that God is not
then God must also be in all that I
perceive to be missing from my life
and therefore in order to become a
manifester and to attract into my life
what I want I simply have to realign
myself
I have to rejoin I have to yoga myself
to God
and the most egregious error of the ego
is a belief system that says that who I
am
is separate
from God
that God is something outside of me
we have not been raised to understand
and believe that at our basic core what
we what lautsu called our original
nature
what we are is love
and all we have to do is be that and
live that
there was a great Indian poet
his name was rabindranath tagore
and he
received the Nobel Prize for literature
in 1913 for a collection of poetry
called the gitanjali
and in that poem that long poem 90 some
verses
one of those verses says this
he's speaking of the ego
he said I went out alone
on my way to my tryst
but who is this me
in the dark
I step aside to avoid his presence but I
escape him not
he makes the dust rise from the earth
with his Swagger
he adds his loud voice to every word I
utter
he is my own little self my Lord
he knows no shame
but I
I am ashamed
to come to thy door
in his company
that's a great poet
and that's a great piece of Truth
that in order to get to this place we I
speak about that Maslow spoke to me
about and trained me to think about
called self-actualization
is that we have to
stop
evaluating who we are on the basis of
those ego identifiers
and instead begin to see ourselves
as Divine love
we live in a
celebrity obsessed world don't we
look at me
notice me
the thou teaches something completely
the opposite
listen to the 66th verse of the Dao
water again the sea stays low and
because the sea stays low all of the
rivers and all of the streams empty into
it
because it stays humble because it stays
in that place of just allowing
everything to come to you he was trying
to teach us
the important lesson of letting what we
know is coming come to us
I practice this so much more now in my
life than I did at one time
I could remember years ago
I was uh I had written a book called
your erroneous zones back in the 70s and
um
it stayed on the New York Times
bestseller list for something like 27
months and each many weeks it would be
number one and then it would go down to
number three and then it would go to
number two and down to seven and all of
that and I was doing The Tonight Show in
those days on a regular basis and so
many of the other shows the Merv Griffin
and the Phil Donahue and Dinah Shore I
became like a regular on the diner show
I was like you know hobnobing with Burt
Lancaster folks and you know just the
and um
what you do is you call and find out
where you appear on the uh on the
bestseller list for the following week
on Wednesday so you call up on Wednesday
not for the Sunday coming up but for the
following week
and I called home and my ego was pretty
strong and I was very much into a lot of
notice me I I really believe that true
nobility is is not about being better
than anyone else now it's it's about
being better than you used to be and I
think I'm better than I used to be in
just about I mean I know that I'm better
than I used to be in every quality or
every characteristic that I hold to be
valuable
um but in those days I was into notice
me
and I called home and I had trained my
wife to call the New York Times she had
this special number that she could call
and with a certain code and she could
find out where I was going to appear on
the bestseller list the following week
so I called her up and I said
where am I on the best seller next next
week you know out in California doing
something and she said
you're not on the best seller list
I said what are you talking about I was
number one on the best seller this last
week I said my even my voice changed
what do you mean I'm not on the best
seller this she said you're not on the
best seller list I'm sorry
she said your book
is I'm the best seller
[Music]
big distinction there isn't it between
believing that this is me and
recognizing that you can let go a little
bit of of that listen to uh verse 66 of
the Dao why is the Sea King of a hundred
streams because it lies below them
humility gives it its power
that's a very important principle to
understand and I live
on the ocean right next to it it's my
front yard and always I watch it to
learn something from this thing called
the ocean which is the most powerful
source of life that we have on the
planet without it there's no life on
this planet and because it stays low so
what does this have to say to us
do you have the capacity to get past
that ego need to always be saying notice
me look how important I am I mean
there's been a proliferation of this
lately with this celebrity silly stuff
isn't it I mean CNN is doing you know
full hour shows on uh on silly little
things about what happened to this
particular celebrity or what happened to
that celebrity and the celebrities never
even done anything and it's uh there's
all of this talk about it and all of the
new magazines I mean and you look you go
into through an airport and you look on
the newsstand and all the same photos
just with different magazines I don't
even know what what the names of all of
them are but there's like this huge
market now that we have for people to
get into a state of notice me Notice Me
notice me and how much do we train our
young people particularly in our schools
and so on that the one who is the star
is the one who gets the most attention
the one who is uh the most important and
the most valuable is the one that has uh
the most people liking them and so on
this constant obsession with needing to
be noticed when in fact
what I have found for myself is the
the happiest moments of my life are when
I can do it low and slow and not have
anybody out there even know what I'm
doing to be able to I mean Louise never
would have uh advertise the fact of some
of the things I talk about with her
generosity she does it anonymously it's
almost always done in those ways no look
at me look and notice me how important I
am and so on
so much to learn from that kind of
wisdom from that kind of interconnection
to The Tao the ability and the
willingness to say to do it anonymously
to say that you can just get done almost
anything that you want to get done if
you don't become obsessed with taking
credit for it remember the movie The
Magnificent Obsession
the movie made back I think in the 50s
and it was really about what was the
Magnificent Obsession it was the ability
to be able to give anonymously what is
Alcoholics Anonymous it is everybody
stays Anonymous nobody has a title
there's not even anybody in charge
there's nobody there's no leaders of
this there's no president there's no
vice president there's no organization
there's no it's just here's here's a
group of people who just want to help
other people whose lives are out of
control so here's a meeting place and
you come and some one day somebody will
will chair it and then somebody else
another day will share it and one of the
things I found and when I attend one of
these meetings
um is that I I feel you'll see so many
people who are down trodden
who feel
as if their life has passed them by who
look like they don't have any teeth they
haven't shaved they're they're dirty
they're
um
God in Disguise Mother Teresa was asked
the question about what she does when
she was in Calcutta and she said every
day every day I see Jesus Christ
in all of his distressing disguises all
of his distressing disguises that you
can see this Source you can see the dial
you can see it when particularly in
those who are the most obscure the most
uh
isolated from everyone else and whenever
I go to one of those meetings and I hear
people get up and they tell their
stories
they
I I always I feel that I feel there's so
much presence of the source of God of
spirit of Lao Tu of this of the sort of
Dao whatever you want to call it in one
of those meetings than I've ever felt in
any church
I've I've never felt the presence of it
more and I encourage you any of you
watching this right now
go to one of those meetings you don't
have to be an alcoholic you don't have
to I'm not an alcoholic I don't call
myself an alcoholic I was never out of
control I drank but I wasn't out of
control and I uh but I still go to those
meetings I have people in my own family
that have struggled with addiction and I
go with them and I sit there and I
listen to those stories and I just I get
shivers down my back when I think about
how beautiful it is to be in the
presence of people all they want to do
is help each other there's a movie
called my name is Bill W
James Woods play the gym James Garner
isn't it and uh he his life just got
totally out of control with addictions
totally out of control and then he went
to a uh uh he he went to one of these
meetings and he began to realize and he
said we can we can actually take these
uh
these people and all we have to do is
all we have to do is love them all we
have to do is all and he's so excited
about the concept of being able to go
out there and and offer it and I keep
referring to Louise because
she's such a hero to me
um there was a time back in the 80s when
our president wasn't even able to say
the word AIDS was he I mean he could
come on and here was this lady who
before this thing became the worldwide
phenomenon that it is was having
meetings in her own house and going and
bringing these people these downtrodden
people who had been labeled outcasts in
society and offering them a place to
learn how to love each other and to care
for each other this was long before
there was any celebrity State status
associated with trying to end this
horrible crisis that our country has and
our world has has had
there was uh James Wood so excited about
the idea of we can create a place where
we're Anonymous nobody has to know
anything about us we don't have to say
our names we don't have to say anything
we just have to come there and we can
help each other and before that happened
everybody who got out of control with
addictions particularly with alcohol
would
die
there was no cure there was no cure and
where did they find their cure they
found it in being anonymous they found
it in being obscure they found it in
having no organization they found it in
having no elected representative they
found it in having no rules there are no
rules you just come and we care if
you've been one day or one hour sober or
even if you're drunk you come we care
about you and you are not that alcohol
who you are is this Divine soul in the
36th verse of the doubted Ching it says
the gentle
Outlast the strong
the Obscure
outlasts the obvious
try to become a little more obscure a
little less interfering a little less
notice me a little less you know one of
the specific kinds of things that you
can do is just as you're about when
somebody else is talking just as you're
about to interject what you've been
thinking about for the whole time
waiting for them to stop talking
just to just stop and to bite your
tongue and say tell me more or that's
very interesting I have never heard that
point of view before even if they
totally completely disagree with
everything that you stand for to be to
be willing to listen to being able to
stop you practice it I practiced it when
I did these verses of the Dao I practice
it every single day while I was working
on that just staying obscure and for me
that's not always so easy because of
just being recognized wherever I go and
if I saw someone who's about to
recognize me I would just put my head
down I would just walk a little bit past
them like so I'm saying right now I just
want to be anonymous right now I want to
be obscure
the Dow says
storms always end verse 23 Fierce Winds
Don't Blow all morning
a downpour of rain doesn't last all day
who does this Heaven and Earth
you're already connected to everything
you want or need it will come to you at
the exact perfect time as the rivers and
the streams come to the ocean at the
perfect time and place
you've got to trust you got to know it's
going to come to you you don't have to
chase after it you can become a little
less obsessed with your ego and your
self-importance and who you are and what
you've done and you can get so much more
done and you know what it's the most
peaceful and sweet delicious way it's
like the song that Cecilia was singing
about the rose your challenges don't
only make you stronger they allow you to
serve better I think the default answer
for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
they put in your way allow you to have a
a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humor they're built to serve
you are built to serve when you can
connect the challenge that you're going
through as something that's then going
to inspire and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to just being about me getting
stronger I find a lot of times me
getting stronger is not enough it's not
enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road reported the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
it was my first ever tour and then I
broke my neck two-thirds of the way
through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this is a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not so I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
which is great for speaking but sucks
for everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues
things like believing you're not good
enough lack of self-worth you don't have
a message to share imposter syndrome all
of those things right even here we're
filming we're about to go through a car
wash
uh we're we're next so we're probably
gonna get some crazy noise we have to
talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time and look
we're next
[Music]
car wash or next depending on how long
that guy ahead of us takes you might you
might see it in this video I dealt with
a lot of those mindset issues those lack
of belief issues those worthiness issues
and I I battled them and I've been
through them and
yeah have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did the path can
be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I'd never been through anything
really physical you know I've broken my
toe
I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run and I was
doing Instagram live at the times like a
light run fast Jog and I like my toe was
hurting so much and I just kept powering
through I didn't later realize I broke
my toe but that's not really anything
major right you know if somebody's going
through something physical and major
it's like you broke your toe come on
it's not a big deal and so I never felt
like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
I had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through it and I don't
feel right pushing people on things that
I haven't experienced in some form
myself right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I might have a concussion I'm
in more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potential having spinal surgery which is
crazy scary but also not being able to
think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations
you know the first couple the first
night in the hospital I was a you know a
train wreck then I came home and uh to
our Airbnb they let me out of the
hospital and I remember two specific
Moments One trying to get into the car
so we're at the hospital I get
discharged I'm excited to go home fresh
air oh my gosh it's amazing and I have
this neck brace on I can't move I'm very
low flexibility and I'm now the
passenger I'm not allowed to drive
because I can't turn my head so Nina has
to Nina has to drive and I'm in the
parking lot of the hospital
and
I'm trying to get into the passenger
side I'm in the passenger seat right now
in my car I'm trying to get into the
passenger side of the car and I can't
and it hurts too much and I get to the
point where I have one foot in the car
and one foot out of the car
and it's a Suburban so this is giant
step up to get in
and I remember being so
I was in so much pain
that I couldn't go forward into the car
I didn't have the strength and every
time I lift it off it killed everything
in my body the whole like all my back up
into my neck everything was in massive
pain but I also couldn't get back down
because that was hurting too much too so
I was in I was stuck in this limbo if I
can't go forward I can't go back
[Music]
Nina's trying to you know push me up to
get me in and I remember just crying
I'm in the parking lot of that oh we're
going in the car wash I'm in the parking
lot I'm gonna have to talk louder I'm in
the parking lot
of the hospital and I'm crying
out of frustration and I can't remember
the last time I was that frustrated that
I just broke down and cried and I I
didn't know what to do next everything
hurt I can't move forward I can't move
backwards I'm just overwhelmed by pain
and frustration and I'm crying in the
parking lot of the hospital
eventually Nina
just pushes me in
one hand on each butt cheek and like in
you go and I got it and it hurt but but
then I was in
and that was just
an overwhelming moment
and then I remember that night
here we go car wash
that night
uh it was I mean I can't sleep it's
terrible i've got you know neck brace on
I'm not used to sleeping with it I'm in
massive pain and it's it's three in the
morning
and I have to go to the bathroom
and so I'm sitting I I can get myself to
sit up they taught me in the hospital
how to push yourself from
um
lying down to
to sitting up oh look here comes look at
the foam look at that guys how to go
from lying down to sitting up without
hurting yourself too much like
minimizing the pain as much as possible
so they taught me how to do that
so three in the morning I have to go to
the bathroom I get up uh I push myself
into the seating position
I'm starting to feel dizzy I have a
concussion right I'm starting to feel
dizzy I can't see anything because it's
really dark and
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
fall over
how I got the concussion was I fainted I
fainted my head on the wall and then
cracked my my the back of my neck open
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
faint and I might fall over again
and I Nina's asleep next to me
were you sleeping on the floor Linda's
joining in no you're on the bed
on the floor
she was afraid she's gonna wake me up I
mean bless Nina's Hearts I mean she had
no sleep during this whole time too
right so she's asleep it's three in the
morning and I and I
I don't want to wake her up
one because I'd feel bad for her because
she hasn't slept at all but also I feel
helpless I feel so helpless
that I mean all this pain and I can't
even go I can't even go to the bathroom
by myself like I need help to go to the
bathroom I felt so helpless and I said
it's it's not worth it for me to get up
and and potentially like if I fall
that's that's that's no bueno right I'm
back to the hospital probably if I fault
so I wake up Nina and I mean it may not
seem like a big deal but it it felt like
a big deal like I felt just helpless
and so I had yeah I woke her up she
helped me go to the bathroom and you
know I did my business and went back to
sleep but
those two moments in particular were the
most painful moments of that whole
experience
it's the best uh
and and the thing that got me through it
the thing that gave me the motivation
was that
hopefully somebody else who's going
through some kind of painful moment
right now
we'll be able to resonate with this and
be inspired by this whether it's
actually true or not it was a story that
I was telling myself I told myself
somebody's going to be inspired by this
and I still made videos and my next
round of videos I couldn't do the whole
thing so Nina did some of it I did some
of it
um and I'm sitting there I'm I'm now
overweight because I'm uh you know I
haven't been able to work out
um I haven't been eaten as clean as I
was normally I got a giant scab if you
look at some of those old videos I have
this huge scab on my forehead again
normally like oh my gosh I got this
giant scab on my you might be worried
about a little pimple look at this giant
scab coming down my forehead it looked
like Harry Potter the thing that gets me
through it is
other people
who have some kind of issue like to
having a bad hair day or a pimple on
their face might be inspired by this to
go and take action what Nina has a
paintball art if you want to show
everybody your pimple on your forehead
again whether it's true or not it was a
story that I was telling myself that
somebody else is going to be inspired by
this and it's going to allow them to go
and do their thing
um now fast forward
make the videos we release the videos a
lot of people were inspired by a lot of
people did message me DM me email me
tell me in future interviews you know I
was I was telling myself I couldn't do
this because of X because I had a
headache
and here you are doing your videos with
a concussion
giant Scout on your face neck brace in
massive pain breaking your neck and I
told myself what I have no excuse I'm
gonna go do my thing because Evan did
his thing
but again whether it was true or not
the thing that got me to get through the
challenge in a way that I'm proud of
myself for
was the connection to service
that it's not just here to make me
stronger which it did made me incredibly
like I can't believe I did that that guy
is still in me that I could go and do
that again hopefully they'll break my
neck again but I could do that
It Made Me Stronger but even more
valuable
is me feeling like this is gonna mean
something to somebody else so whatever
challenge you're going through
understand that yes you know your
purpose comes from your pain
this will make you a better person
but the thing that will help you get
through it at least to my experience is
connecting to somebody else
that there are tons of people out there
who are also struggling with the same
thing that you are struggling with right
now and when you get through it your
story will be an inspiration for them
your journey through it
will motivate them to have the courage
to show up for their lives as well and
when you can actually connect it to
service I think everything is better you
are built to serve we made it through
the car wash
[Laughter]
good job Nina hopefully that uh you
heard all that stuff and it was valuable
and life-changing and if not I love you
anyway
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
more incredible Wayne Dyer motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there people who are
not good at giving away love
can't give away love because they don't
have it to give away if I want to give
you a dozen oranges